alors je sais pas vous mais moi ce soir
j'apprends beaucoup
j'apprends beaucoup et d'ailleurs on ne
serait pas dans l'enceinte d'une école
on s'y croirait presque
on apprend beaucoup mais d'une autre
manière ce qu'on a en tête quand on
parle de l'école parfois ça ressemble
plutôt à ça mais là ce soir s'est passé
là parce que je suis pas professeur il
n'y a pas de tableau noir derrière moi
d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas des élèves et
surtout les étudiants à cette heure-ci
le vendredi soir général ils sont pas à
l'école
lorsqu'on est en train d'expérimenter ce
soir c'est peut-être plus l'école
d'aujourd'hui
dans quelques semaines les vidéos des
interventions seront disponibles sur
internet
et puis vous pourrez les regarder depuis
votre canapé vous pourrez même décidé de
mettre sur pause n'avait procrastiner un
petit peu devant le frigo et puis de
revenir en vous disant qu' il faut faire
des courses et deux qu'il faut continuer
votre apprentissage
non en fait ce soir je pense qu'on est
vraiment en train d'expérimenter ce que
c'est qu'un nouveau genre d'école alors
qu'est ce que c'est que l'école de
demain
qu'est ce que à quoi cette école va nous
former et qu'est ce que les enfants
d'aujourd'hui devront savoir faire dans
le monde de demain
c'est important de se poser cette
question vous êtes peut-être par an moi
je serai peut-être bientôt et je me pose
cette question qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
devoir apprendre ça bouge tellement vite
aujourd'hui nos enfants ils vont être
con ils vont être face à d
à des problèmes extrêmement complexe et
étendu que soit le gaspillage
alimentaire le réchauffement climatique
l'accès à l'éducation l'accès au
logement nos enfants ils vont devoir
apprendre à travailler sur des
thématiques qui font sens normal je me
pose une question aussi est ce qu'ils
vont en avoir envie parce qu'après tout
il pourrait faire comme nous on pourrait
avoir envie de polluer envie de
gaspiller en vue de faire fortune ce
qu'ils vont avoir envie de ça parce
qu'en fait on leur laisse pas vraiment
le choix
euh là ce sont ilona et merlan ils ont
12 ans et alors il ya quelques semaines
ils sont venus nous voir dans nos
bureaux pour nous expliquer que ils
cherchaient des matériaux dans le
quartier pour je les cite créer un
système de récupération de l'eau et de
traitement autonome de l'eau parce que
chez nous on a de l'eau potable dans les
toilettes mais dans certains pays ils
n'ont pas de litres d'eau par jour pour
boire pourquoi ils font ça
ici le reprend ils ont 12 ans on est
mercredi après midi
jma il pourrait aller jouer au foot par
la corde à sauter à l'oreille au cheval
je sais pas non ils viennent nous
expliquer un problème qui leur tient
extrêmement hackers nous parler de
problèmes de personnes qui sont à des
milliers de km2
en fait je me suis étonné de la même
manière il ya trois ans en découvrant un
mouvement des personnes de paris à sao
paulo à cape town qui dépensait leur
temps leurs compétences et leur énergie
à travailler sur des problèmes
extrêmement complet ce complexe est
vraiment sur leur temps libre avec leurs
passions passer des soirées entières à
travailler avec des post it en utilisant
des méthodes qu'on n'avait jamais
apprises nulle part avec que des
inconnus il se passionnait pour ça
parfois ils allaient même jusqu'à
traverser des frontières plusieurs pour
se retrouver à 100 à 150 à 200 et
travailler sur ces problèmes pendant
tout un week-end pourquoi ils faisaient
ça mais aussi ce que je trouve est
fascinant c'est que il n'était pas du
tout ni gaver ni écoeuré par ces
problèmes dont on nous narre tous les
jours non ils leur demandaient et en
fait je pense que il appliquait à la
lettre un très sec qui nous a été
enseigné par un vieux professeur c'est
que si on avait une heure pour sauver le
monde
on passerait 55 minutes à définir le
problème et cinq minutes à trouver la
solution
autrement dit il ya peut-être plus de
solutions que de problèmes si on prend
le problème comme ça et surtout trouver
toutes les solutions à un même problème
lorsqu'on l'a bien défini peut devenir
un jeu en fait ce que nous apprennent
les personnes de make sense à paris à
sao paulo à cape town
ce que nous apprennent ilona et merlin
c'est que les problèmes de notre société
sont en réalité passionnant et que
lorsqu'on travaille sur les sujets qui
nous touche profondément
on fait avec beaucoup plus d'intérêt
cette démultiplie notre propre intérêt
pour ces sujets donc ça nous permet
d'apprendre
alors à prendre dans ce contexte ça
redonne véritablement du sens à l'école
ilona merlin et les personnes de make
sense m'ont donné une conviction c'est
que quand on travaille sur les
problématiques qui nous touche
personnellement ça donne un véritable
réacteurs à votre soif d'apprendre et sa
de cette conviction et non métier
aujourd'hui on travaille depuis deux ans
à permettre à n'importe quel individu de
trouver les causes qui lui tiennent
profondément à coeur et d'apprendre à
partir de ça je vous donne quelques
exemples ciel bleu est une entreprise
sociale
l'entreprise qui s'est créée pour
répondre à un problème que ses
fondateurs ont identifié dans la société
le problème auquel répond ciel bleu
c'est le bien-être de la population
vieillissante que nous serons un jour la
solution qu'ils ont imaginé permettrait
de réduire le déficit de la sécurité
sociale de près de 59 milliards d'euros
d'ici à 2020 ya aucune technologie c'est
de la gym douce ce qu'on appelle des
activités physiques adaptées
un jour ils ont rencontré un problème
il se demandait comment on pouvait
permettre aux personnes âgées qui
suivait ses cours de gym douce de
poursuivre ces exercices à la maison du
coup il a fallu inventer des objets qui
allait servir spécifiquement à cet usage
et ce défi on l'a proposé à romain et à
cet autre de ses camarades il était
designers ingénieurs business woman
tous ensemble ils sont allés faire les
exercices de gym douce ils ont imaginé
40 croquis d'objets finalement ils ont
créé 6 et parmi ces objets y en a trois
qui ont permis à ciel bleu de d'aller
chercher de l'argent et d'industrialiser
ses trois premiers objets au final ce
qu'on fait roman et ses camarades
c'est bien plus que créer des objets ils
ont permis à 60000 personnes chaque
semaine de mieux vivre leur vieillesse
vous imaginez l'impact de ça quand vous
dites vous êtes jeunes moi où j'ai fait
ça ça vous donne des ailes un autre
exemple 0 gâchis chaque année plus de
750 mille tonnes de nourriture sont
jetés parce que ils arrivent à date
limite de consommation
avant de quitter les rayons des
supermarchés 0 gâchis permet de limiter
le gaspillage alimentaire qui est fait
dans les grandes surfaces en vous
permettant de géolocaliser celles qui
sont autour de vous dans lesquelles ces
produits arrivent à date de limite de
consommation et dont le prix est réduit
après s'être attaqué à la grande surface
0 gâchis ont voulu réduire le gaspillage
alimentaire sur les lieux de
restauration étudiante soit dans des
endroits où il est servi plus de 300
mille repas par jour là encore julien et
ses sept camarades sont partis sur le
terrain sont allés rencontrer des
étudiants dans les restaurants
universitaires
pas facile de passer inaperçu et auprès
du personnel de restauration et des
entreprises qui les approvisionner ils
ont pas imaginer un outil pour réduire
le gaspillage alimentaire non ils ont
imaginé un outil pour faciliter la vie
des étudiants pourquoi parce que sur le
terrain ils se sont rendus compte que ce
qui révolte est les étudiants s'étaient
pas le gaspillage alimentaire dans leur
assiette
non c'était le fait de devoir faire la
queue pour aller déjeuner le midi et en
fait dans cette application ils ont
ajouté une simple fonction qui permet de
quantifier qu'est-ce qui est pris dans
les plateaux repas qu'est-ce qui est
laissé dans ces plateaux repas et ces
données sont envoyées au crous
aujourd'hui grâce au travail de julien
et ses camarades 0 gâchis afin un
partenariat avec le crous et est en
train de d'expérimenter l'outil concret
et les étudiants what the food dans
toute la région parisienne avec pour
objectif de l'étendre à tout le
territoire
alors en fait je pense que l'école
demain elle va pas nous former à des
métiers nous mêmes à apprendre un métier
je pense que l'école de demain elle doit
permettre de se passionner pour des
sujets et s'accomplir là dedans parce
que la technologie des machines tout ça
va changer mais nous nous on est des
humains et nous on sera là demain et
l'envié d'apprendre
c'est ça qui nous rend humain il faut
rapprocher l'école des sujets qui
passionnent les étudiants qui passionne
les élèves des sujets qui les touchent
personnellement
pourquoi on décroche des maths à l'école
vous souvenez c'est quand la dernière
fois que vous avez tracé un triangle
avec un stylo bille est une règle les
fonctions affine pythagore à quoi ça
sert mais c'est vraiment ça qu'on se
demande à l'époque à l'école à quoi ça
va me servir rapprocher les causes des
étudiants de leur apprentissage
c'est la clé parce qu'en fait on a tous
quelque chose à apporter sur cette
planète
et lorsqu on résout le défi de 0 gâchis
le défi de ciel bleu
lorsqu'on s'occupe d'un problème d'eau
potable à des milliers de kilomètres en
fait on se sent plus aguerris dans ce
monde on a un impact sur lui alors
l'autre bonne nouvelle c'est que quand
on a répondu quand on a apporté une
solution à un problème aussi complexe et
tendue que le gaspillage alimentaire
les employeurs se bat pour vous avoir
pourquoi parce que la passion que vous
avez développé pour un sujet vous
permettre de développer une créativité
qui va vous paraître d'aller bien au
delà du problème vous permettent de
développer votre empathie et de mieux
comprendre l'environnement dans lequel
il s'inscrit
vous permettre d'avoir la persévérance
nécessaire pour aller au bout du
blême il faut développer l'apprentissage
par l'action sur ses causes parce que ça
développe sa déclenché des vocations
mais pas nécessairement des vocations
d'entrepreneurs sociale des vocations
d'hommes ou de femmes politiques non une
sorte d' intime conviction
quelque chose qui vous prend aux tripes
qui vous fait une petite brûlure qui
vous donne envie pensée l'école comme un
outil comme une institution qui a pour
vocation de donner envie ça ça nous sort
du cadre et les tice traditionnel mais
en fait l'école de demain
on y trouve des élèves passionnés
passionné par des sujets qui
construisent la planète ça on ne l'a
déjà dit à son temps maria montessori
première femme médecin en italie nous
disait que éduquer ce n'est pas quelque
chose que font les professeurs c'est un
processus naturel du développement
humain et que éduquer l'école c'est donc
permettre donner un cadre à l'expression
notre curiosité spontanée alors ce que
je vais vous dire ce soir c'est que que
ce soit ilona ilona julien romain vais
me dira peut-être que il était déjà
passionné ou très engagé dans ses sujets
avant de commencer à relever ces défis
vous avez raison mais c'est pas ça qui
est important ce qui est vraiment
important c'est que ces trois là on ont
entraîné 1000 et 2000 autres derrière
eux qui ont fait naître leur petite
brûlure alors euh moi vous on sait pas
de quoi demain sera fait par contre on
peut tous commencé par se poser une
question ce soir sur quelle cause avez
vous envie d'agir demain